speaking of the original cast of first
west club I hear you ran into Goldie
Hawn which is awesome I would have just
started saying lines from Bird on a Wire
like all the films from my childhood
because they do well with meeting icons
though I don't know if you've noticed it
was a good thing we weren't there
together first of all it's embarrassing
because I was at the psychics you're at
a psychic psychic now guide kick I was
at the psychic everything is gonna work
out in my life you know and I guess
Goldie want to know that everything's
gonna work out in her life and it was
right when the wind cated had the next
her third baby the little girl and I
like to think the door opened and there
she was and I was like I know my psychic
isn't golden huh that's where my MA our
brains right heaven in I just I realized
she wasn't the psychic and I was like oh
my god what did she do she did this she
was like thank you that's kind of how I
feel Merrill got scared of me I was loud
though she should have been Scout was
excited I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this